car tester Ronnie is looking to buy a
place to live but it's not so easy to
find the right apartment that gives you
all you want and fits your budget
[Music]
they talk Ronnie says he spent days
looking for the perfect apartment this
newspaper is nothing to offer
so he's considering other options like
the mercedes-benz
as 500 Cabriolet it costs about the same
as an apartment so he's wondering
whether he should just move into the S
500 instead and save himself the hassle
he's going to test it out maybe it's
just what he needs was forbidden cooking
up a stuff like the benefit Mercedes
brought out the s-class convertible in
2016 reviving a popular format that at
last used 45 years before it's Mercedes
first luxury convertible 4 seater since
1971 developers unique design all the
advanced engineering of the s-class and
a comprehensive heating and wind
protection system if you're looking to
cruise it doesn't get much more
exclusive than this Ronnie is impressed
with the ultra smooth ride thanks to the
air suspension you can drive over a
brick road and not even notice then
under the hood you have a v8 twin
turbocharged engine which is so quiet
it's unbelievable when you have the top
up you can't hear the engine at all it's
amazing especially when you consider the
monstrous 335 kilowatts of power under
the hood that provides a massive 700
Newton meters of torque as low as just
1,800 revs the luxury cruiser powers
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour and
just 4.6 seconds the top speed is
electronically capped at 250 kilometers
an hour
[Music]
yeah often Rami says when you're driving
with the top down you're bound to get
thirsty so make sure you have a
resealable bottle to drink from like
this one
strangely despite all the luxury there's
no drinks holder here so if you only
have a can you're either going to have
to drink it in one go or stay thirsty
thinking oh
if you want to get noticed the s500 is
definitely an option at list for 140,000
euros in Germany and it shows the
convertible is quite a statement and
guaranteed to turn heads with its long
nose angular lines and sleek aerodynamic
design
[Music]
[Applause]
the car is just over 5 meters long and
the epitome of sleek elegance but the
s500 doesn't overdo it
retaining a cool confidence that knows
it has nothing to prove the interior is
pure luxury wherever you look here the
focus is very much on the passengers
comfort but is that enough to replace
having a home of your own Ronny has
found himself a plot of land to park his
beautiful piece of real estate he wants
to test that how suitable the car is for
everyday living
obviously the s500 doesn't have a stove
but every surface you come in contact
with can be heated so in theory you
could use the armrest to thaw out or
even heat up a piece of cake cooling off
tone what does the government after
eating an afternoon nap is just the
thing that's certainly no problem few
cars have seats that adjust as well as
the s510 sit very comfortable and
there's plenty of legroom you can also
switch on the massage function it has
five different settings for back and
shoulders surely no living room couch
offers unic this level of comfort
but sleeping under open skies isn't
everyone's thing one press of a button
closes the top which with its double
glazing and insulation materials turns
the S 502 a perfectly protected and
quiet place to sleep the whole thing
takes just 20 seconds and also works
while you're out on the road if the
weather suddenly changes provided you're
not driving more than sixty kilometres
an hour before Ronnie could drive on he
urgently needs to use a restroom luckily
his plot of land is part of a
development site equipped with
facilities now it's time to get back to
the road where our test car really
belongs there's no doubt about the
all-round excellence of the new s-class
convertible the v8 engine taken from the
s 500 coupe a fits perfectly with the
character of this rock-solid cruiser
so would Ronnie buy a car like this
instead of an apartment if he had the
choice between a house or an S 500
Cabrio eat up for the house but if he'd
already had his own home and could still
afford it
he'd definitely take the S 500 kibriya
it's the perfect car for summer and
guaranteed it gets you noticed cell
phone